you say that you've had this knee
problem and that you're gonna have to
get it operated on I heard this story
recently this better be a good story
buddy
well okay I heard this story that you're
having sex no I'm just I just want to
get your attention here
no I heard this story that you were on a
movie set and that you either way who
told you I was having sex because Andy
has binoculars and he's looking I always
tell him to check out the guest the day
before they come on the show he's heaven
sucks yeah yeah he doesn't even own
binoculars he just goes like that with
his hand yeah no what I was saying is
that I heard that you were on a movie
set with John Krasinski and you
challenged him to a footrace
is that true yeah yeah you're a again
you're a 69 year old man we're about to
get a new knee the last thing that goes
after your athletic prowess is the love
of talking trash so you know you're not
gonna beat him right but the idea of
talking trash so effectively that he
begins to think maybe you might there's
such joy in that so what so what
happened you don't drive on this ice
floe it was in you know in Alaska and we
it was one of those things where it was
a scene that had about 15 principles in
it and it took three weeks so you'd say
your two lines right one day and then
you were in the background for the rest
of the two weeks night so you got bored
and you'd do silly things like on camera
we were supposed to be running towards
something I go I'm gonna kick her ass
I'm gonna just beat you so I tripped him
I pulled on things in a you know and
clearly he does clean my clock but yeah
he's he's an incredible athlete he's
good he's in great shape not that you're
not an amazing shape he was better he
was not in good shape when he was doing
comedies now he's doing this like hero
stuff
he bulked up he's in good shape yeah
that's what I'm gonna do when I get into
superhero action films yeah this is just
my comedy body
you
you